welcome to this video playing powerloom
on let's see prog boy no I wouldn't have
guessed that one let's see yeah I'm
going to play a king's indian aiming for
a complicated position yeah normally
yeah okay and people know what they do
like Age 3 or whatever they have their
their line mapped out beforehand I am
Bishop e3 think you can you can do that
it's not necessary but night h5 is a
possible possible move mmm maybe it
should be too yeah ok so i can go f5
yeah there is no apparent to draw back
to that Oh what isn't this in peace
hmm that's just a piece a piece is a
piece as a piece yeah gfgf it still has
no square five I guess he had to take
forfeits due to disconnection okay yeah
yeah that was not really a long game
what can you do should upload that Heron
oh well this is a good set up against h3
let's make a little theoretical / viewer
now about that um here after d5 black
has essentially two things as it is
disposal he can play Knight h5
immediately now obviously angling for a
five or you can start with 9 a-6 the
move Knight a6 is very often played
nowadays in many Kings Indian variations
it's a very flexible move that looks at
those kind of squares those tiles of
squares which might come in handy as a
fight for the c3 e4 square especially
for the night is out of the way so there
are possibilities to connect rooks later
if you imagine Bishop d7 Queen moves
rooks are connected this is a far more
flexible way of playing the night d 7 in
contrast this is a rather inflexible
move yeah night a 6 he played this one
and the White has a choice here the
choice is Bishop e3 or Bishop g5 Bishop
g5 is a little bit more popular nowadays
the idea is simply comparable to the
Petrosian variation that this pin is an
annoying feature of the position so
black is either provoked to play h6
after which you drop back or to play
Queen e8 to get rid of the pin after
queenie eight black still or again
retains the option to move the night and
5h 6 is the most common move after which
white drops back why is Bishop g5 III an
interesting way to play it isn't this
losing a tempo hmm in a way yes it gives
up a move or you can give he gave black
the extra h6 move however the move aged
6 is of questionable value um there are
reasons for why this is sometimes age 6
can be a square for black piece that
sounds weird but I can give you an
example let's say this is played just
just a sample line this this going a 5 a
3 & let's say black plays h4 a foyer
trying to block the Queen side here if
wide now grab this pond which is
possibility then all of a sudden if you
imagine this position all of a sudden
this Bishop comes to life which is not
possible when the pawn is on age 6 ok
black could play h5 Bishop h6 ok but
here this is just a very important
feature of the position that this Bishop
can be activated on the age 6 square the
more important part however is that the
move age six if we look at it the move
h6 weakens the g6 pawn or square um this
gets very important whenever black plays
f5 if we imagine let's say black plays
Queen you ate night back right here this
and then five and now we see that this
is a week square week porn also this can
be used sometimes even this is a maybe
not an ideal way to play let's say this
is happening right like here here f5 in
those cases this move for example it's
all of a sudden attacking stuff this is
a different scenario to when the pawn is
on age seven so provoking the eighteenth
h6 is quite often useful this is why
Bishop g5 nowadays is played a little
bit more often
after Bishop e3 I went night h5 with
this idea which is not necessarily that
great night on f4 is nice but let's say
white place 92 in this case and move
like night f4 is just leading to nothing
and I have to retreat so it's not clear
that he has to play the move g3 but this
is what he did now if I go at five I
think about that why it has to reckon
with ideas like black has to reckon with
ideas like 95 in this case it is unclear
because i have this counter sacrifice
but I was reluctant to play a five then
I went here to prepare that and have an
eye on this night yeah and now he played
92 + f5 yeah and now he has to take on
f5 there is really no no alternative to
that maybe some move yeah and not no not
really I mean this is what he has to do
and here we see that Queenie age was a
useful preparation for the f5 push yeah
now maybe this night back and we go go
from here complicated position we see
that black has this mobile porn center
but why it has ideas to attack it
sometimes even with g4 not immediately
this is again bluntness apiece but it
cannot be an idea later to play g4 not
dislodging the f5 point so that if or
becomes a square yeah a very short game
but maybe you got some information about
some Kings Indian structures in the
three line to make it a worthwhile video
to watch hope you liked it thanks for
watching